Salut la Team Mentalo !
En ce jour des astuces, je vais vous donner 5 tips pour être à l'aise à l'oral.
Par ailleurs si vous êtes abonné à la chaîne, en fin de vidéo j'aurai deux annonces à vous faire.
Pour les abonnés.
Etre à l'aise à l'oral, ça peut être à l'aise devant une personne à qui on doit défendre un discours,
un propos, quelque chose qu'on a à vendre, comme un examen par exemple.
Ça peut être aussi une prise de parole devant toute une classe, ou devant tous ses collègues,
ou encore pire, dans une grande conférence devant des centaines et des centaines de personnes.
Mais ça peut aussi être en one to one.
Pour commencer il faut savoir que ce n'est pas inné d’être à l'aise à l'oral.
En effet, c'est pas quelque chose qu'on a en soit dès la naissance, c'est une galère pour tout le monde.
Il n'y a personne qui est né avec la capacité d’être plus à l'aise qu'un autre à l'oral.
5 astuces rapides, puisque là ce n'est pas un Master Class.
Astuce numéro 1:
Vous devez garder à l'esprit que la forme est aussi importante que le fond
un peu comme au restaurant, ça doit être beau dans l'assiette et ça doit être bon dans la bouche.
Il est louche en vrai ce parallèle... Je ne sais pas pourquoi j'ai choisi ça.
Vous devez donc soigner le ton, les intentions, vous devez aussi bien moduler votre voix.
Quelqu'un qui dirait quelque chose de très très pertinent, mais qui parlerait toujours comme ça... [lentement]
tout le long...
tout le temps...
sans jamais de nuances...
On décrocherait immédiatement.
Ça s'est pareil que vous parliez à une personne pour un examen ou que vous parliez à 500 ou devant 1000 personnes pour une conférence.
C'est une espèce de "mini représentation"
Vous devez mettre de la vie là-dedans, un petit comme quand vous parlez à vos amis, à vos potes ou à votre famille,
quand vous leur racontez quelque chose, vous mettez du relief, vous vivez ce que vous racontez.
ça doit être pareil vous devez travailler dans ce sens là.
Deuxième astuce:
Soyez concis. court, court mais efficace.
Quand j'étais formateur bafa dans une autre vie, ça aussi on parlait du CCP:
Clair.
Concis.
Précis.
C'est la règle à adopter quand vous faites un oral.
Même si vous improvisez un travail à l'oral avec quelqu'un, gardez cette règle là en tête ; d’être le plus clair possible
le plus court possible, ne pas partir à droite et à gauche tout le temps, et précis.
Evidemment, il faut que ça touche le but.
Troisième astuce:
Regardez dans les yeux votre interlocuteur.
Pas fixement non plus comme un psycho, mais ne fuyez pas son regard, au contraire allez le chercher.
Vous devez le solliciter, créer un lien avec cette personne, vous devez capter littéralement son attention.
Et si c'est une grande salle, vous devez aller chercher les regards un petit peu partout.
De la même manière il faut reproduire ce naturel dans une conversation que l'on a avec quelqu'un on le fait naturellement
On le perd à un oral donc il faut penser à retrouver ça.
Les yeux !
Tout est dans les yeux !
Quatrième astuce:
Vous devez parler plus fort. On juge assez mal notre puissance vocale, puisqu'on s'entend à la fois par l'extérieur et aussi par l'intérieur, en résonance.
On pense donc qu'on parle toujours assez fort, et c'est faux !
Forcez vous à donner plus de puissance, que ce que vous pensiez donner naturellement.
Et le fait de forcer un petit peu le volume, va vous donner plus naturellement des intentions, des reliefs, des émotions, des pics.
Ca va donner de la matière à votre discours.
Cinquième et dernière astuce:
Souriez ! Soyez enjoué de l'intérieur.
Il ne faut pas avoir un sourire crispé comme ça !
Il faut vraiment se sentir heureux, se sentir bien. Faites-vous un petit discours intérieur avant s'il le faut.
On doit ressentir toute force énergie positive. Allez chercher ce qui a de meilleur en vous et laissez le ressortir sur votre visage.
Rayonnez !
Voilà, c'est même plus que sourire. C'est ça c'est rayonner
Je n'ai volontairement pas parlé du trac. Si vous voulez que je fasse une vidéo dessus, dites-le moi dans les commentaires.
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo. N'oubliez pas qu'après le petit visuel de fin de vidéo j'ai un message pour les abonnés.
Et si vous n’êtes pas abonné, vous pouvez tout de suite le devenir en cliquant sur le petit logo.
Et comme on dit chez moi: Si ça vous a plu n'oubliez pas...
Pouce en l'air !
Rendez-vous comme tous les jours de l'année, demain à 17H pour le prochain Mental Vlog.
Ciao !
Voilà le visuel est terminé. Les deux petites choses que j'avais à vous dire sont simples.
La première c'est qu'hier on a fait la première vidéo par Skype.
D'après vos commentaires cela vous a plu, donc j'en referai. Je ne sais pas encore à quelle fréquence, je ne sais pas si je vais m'imposer un jour précis de semaine
mais soyez à l’affût, je le mettrais toujours sur les réseaux sociaux. On continuera de la même manière, donc par tirage au sort, c'est mieux.
Moi ça m'a vraiment éclaté de faire ça. Si vous aussi, on check !
Et la deuxième chose, vous l'avez d'ailleurs peut-être remarqué, mais plus ça va, plus la chaîne me prend du temps.
Aussi bien dans l'écriture, puisqu'on commence à atteindre les 150 vidéos. Dans son évolution aussi, en tout cas j'espère.
Je fais aussi énormément de formations. Et d'un manière générale je prends plus de temps qu'avant.
Par rapport à tout ça, il était important que je trouve une solution pour faire une espèce de compensation financière.
Parce que sinon je ne vais pas m'en sortir.
J'ai pensé dans un premier temps au fameux tipi mais je trouve que ça ne correspond pas à ce que je fais...
Je ne pourrait pas faire énormément de choses en plus. Même si j'avais pleins de tipeurs.
J'ai donc choisi la solution la plus simple, c'est d'ouvrir toutes les vidéos aux publicités.
Certaines l'étaient déjà mais je n'avais pas coché toutes les options. Donc voilà, j'ai tout fait.
J'espère que ça ne vous dérangera pas, j'espère que vous comprendrez pourquoi j'ai fait ça.
Ça ne va pas me rapporter des millions...mais j'espère que ça me permettra de prendre plus de temps sur les vidéos,
et d’investir un peu dessus.
Voilà, c'est tout. Je trouvais cela important de pouvoir vous l'annoncer, à vous qui êtes abonné depuis le départ ou récemment.
Mais qui faites parti de la Team Mentalo !
C'est tout ce que j'avais à dire ! Alors à demain à 17H !
Ciao !